ils entendent squeeze aujourd'hui je
vais vous affronter sur le jeu vidéo
parce qu'on sait qu'on dessin vous me
battait tout ça sans exception même
votre chat me bat d'ailleurs on est donc
sur un petit jeu un peu la quake en fait
tous est un fps et à deux équipes et tu
as une arme qui one shot lenny culture
en une balle voilà vous allez me
rejoindre et je vais me faire défoncer
et c'est un skipper ce mec me à des
clous dans tous les jeux en ce moment
c'est un vrai scandale
attendez attendez attendez là vous voyez
on est tranquille sur transat ont sauté
boom merbau donc c'est comme quoi qu'on
peut sauter on tire on à ses pieds et
tout ce bordel on attendait le ski
lorsque vous vous bouffe au triple kill
team recule donc là c'est chacun pour
soi et j'ai sorti quelqu'un derrière moi
mais oui on verra qui finira prêt pour
le moment je suis premier on est plutôt
serein aux flammes hop là haut up la
triple crise et c'est au moment où
quelques hommes dans league of legends
détriment des russes il s'appelle des
rues ça non au lit à reus à sa ve
plaisir des enfants vous a fauté mais
c'est vrai j'ai rarement joué
bonjour votre vos finalement excuse moi
je suis un mec entre deux phrases voilà
aux audi dont c'est la collision ça se
met pas de laser en plein à balayage au
balayage toujours ben oui en tout temps
au balayage bien le mot on n'a pas le
temps
jean-michel pas le temps excusez moi
pardon je suis pressée au papa lui s'il
était pressé
l'intérêt a déduit étagère à l'autre
comme ça une ville des coups du sort ce
que soudainement entre les doigts ça ce
congé très très content nous sommes
repartis sur une différente alger fait
de fausse manip et je sais pas juste à
tout casser
voilà et comme l'himalaya de me casser
d'ailleurs alors cette fois on doit buts
et les rouges par exemple lui fit et wii
8 là on est sur un bonbon au plein boom
mauvais move désormais tu fais quoi là
haut
ah oui mais il est malin il est fourbe
mais ça n'a pas suffi ianu salut comment
ça va et toi là haut ça va
moi ça va barder ça va avec ma télé tu
es en fait non
au revoir il faut reprendre du poil de
la bête comme on dit dans le milieu
j'ai encore fait une fausse manoeuvre en
fait quand j'appuie sur f pour
réapparaître alors je rappelle
automatiquement sauf que quand j'appuie
sur f5 type le mode plein écran et se
fait oublier
on prend pas au tristan tués faute
tristan je te vois salut j'ai exposé à
toi tu m'en veux pas bah c'était ianu
quel hasard et je m'envole oh oui puis
bien il m'a bien aidé à m'envoler hop là
où c'était beau ça par contre c'est
extrêmement les hauts et bas prix
essayer non la voile est fou mais c'est
comme ça vous savez ce qui s'est passé
oui vous le savez j'ai encore oublié sur
f pour appareils sauf que ça fait tous
plantés en ya plus yann où il va
tellement de manquer y en a un là à
plein le screamer je serai sûr sauf à
son écran il a peut-être cassé son écran
il fait quoi lui meurt au il est doux et
qq ops je suis caché on va vers la
technique de la coop tué par un ton père
tu au hockey qui ont pu lui nouveau ianu
haut il faut le gagner mais sauf que je
vous le mercato mais ça le cactus et web
peuvent faire des essais qca pas de me
tuer c'est lui qui a si je pouvais lui
te bannir des serveurs je te ferai je ne
crois pas que ousmane a fuck you il
gagne en tuant dernier par là c'est la
phrase que j'ai plus de mal écrire au
monde
gg bien jolis duos on l'applaudît il
nous a tous défoncés
c'est la revanche messieurs dames j'ai
gâché ta partie un peu mais ça m'a fait
très plaisir
voilà
1 mais comment vous faites je saute je
bouge des mouvements aux platines
source c'est ça que je vais faire un
nouveau serveur pour t'éviter brevets
contre toi mon gars mais là je suis trop
mauvais c'est chaud oh oh [ __ ] c'était
magique
oh oui avec un talent fou [ __ ] mais il
va devenir ingénieur pour la nasa stable
sans fonds c'est sûr je vous jure
approche avec [ __ ] mais c'est pas sûr
un jour je voulais me détendre je
rencontre mes abonnés est urgent ouais
tu préfères impute un caca nerveux
je n'en peux plus de cette eau il a
gagné ce smiley ce style et quitte cette
partie va loin pas les deux fours muet
me reconnais que c'est un smiley de
fourbe
oh non j'ai fait un fausse manip bon
j'ai appelé saveurs en voir qu comme au
revoir cure ce n est pas la place en
plein de loin non mais lui il est en
plein mois [ __ ] je veux qu'on gagne
une game vous faire honneur sans aucun
respect of hope la up là haut au des
shows à 12h suis dit il va revenir au
foot à white vient là bientôt quatre
anneaux bien je le méritais voilà jeté
sur un bon feeling là attention ils
remontent les enfants j'ai pas compris
l'homme qui est des mobiles
ouf
bouffe mais qu'at-il ou namur mais
qu'at-il au plus tard là aussi notre vie
faut sauter comme ça et ensuite tu
passes derrière mike et boum
et boum boum et tout compris il a suivi
le tuto squeeze le ce couteau
non la ville il a tout gâché
on était pas mal hop là on est au congo
va mieux
et ouais moi j'ai des petites filles qui
dansent pour moi et pas vous oh il
progresse
nolwenn pour ce coup-ci c'est une petite
fille qui progresse d'accord on
s'assemblent c'est un homme de 35 ans
bien viril on n'en sait rien c'est le
point de l'internet au plat des vagues
les mâles web merci
regardez real c'est beau ce qu'on fait
là impossible de nos visées mais voit
même s'écrit aussi c'est impossible
qu'ils aient d'autres du coup tu vas y
fais quoi lui c'est mon territoire non
il est doué il crée de il a tout compris
la presqu'île on assiste au mais les
gars vous avez vous êtes sérieux aux
tirs au but ont vite trop vite on n'est
pas dedans
voilà les trois bientôt alors au nom
on était en train de remonter il a 29
ans avant de quelqu'un y croient et
parlent et répète parce que c'est
terminé
up like reste une et c'est tout aussi
bon ben c'est là que j'ai pas le temps
qui d'autre voter c'est l'étoile abba
eban yao k c'est nolwenn weiler qu'au
prix d'une alouette
ah non holloway je vais faire génois et
paulo mais j'ai raté vite 5 qu'il
chantera en corse est oui pour lui cette
non arrête de bouger comme ça déjà ça
m'excite puis en suisse et n'a pas lâché
la loi qui nous dit j'ai envie de
pleurer sommes énormes un petit hommage
à la cour par des activités depuis 1962
comme en témoignent ses sacs biceps
on peut même faire la majorette avec ses
magnifiques cas c'est un truc je vois
les gens c'est à dire fin de cette
petite ville et où je jouais contre vous
voilà j'ai envie de faire ça depuis très
longtemps mais je n'ai pas de jeu et ce
petit jeu très simple d'utilisation que
taux d'installation puisque à jouer il
est quand même un peu dur vous êtes très
bien à faire j'espère ça vous a plu ici
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude et je ferai peut-être
des squeeze va s abonner sur d'autres
jeux pourquoi pas parfois mais ça me
regarde et surtout le monde
pis
[Applaudissements]